welcome back to PGA chain design channel
today we are going to design this
captain wheel and we will talk about the
bezel setting right in the middle and
also the besetting around the rim are
you ready let's get started
I have a stone setting course if you are
interesting more about the stone setting
than just a bezel set you can check it
out you can click over here on the right
top corner I will have a link over there
we are going to starting with a center
stone for whatever size that you like if
you want to know how to make the stone I
have a video here on my youtube channel
choose building a stone from scratch now
we have this stone and we need to make a
C for it to making a C we simply just
going to make a rectangle and you can
have the rectangle in any of the size
that you want but be really important is
you need to make sure that the stone is
not cutting over 50% of the wall
thickness I usually like to keep it
about 20 to 30 percent and so that way
that will set the stone patter and what
I wanted to do is also to align and
follow my stone roughly go light this
way and then going up like this and
using that curve to trim off this area
here and again using this curve to trim
the extra over there and I simply can't
just join them together so now this is
the curve that I have I always get the
question like how much meadow I need to
leave over there as soon as you are over
the table area you should be fine
however if you are not so sure you can
always make it a bit longer which is
actually better for you if you don't
have enough metal you can just if you
have it too much extra and you can just
fire it down make sure that the kulluk
is not sticking out on the button
you want to leave at least point five
meaning me there or more that way your
stone won't isolate and set it to low
and then click it's kind of stick out
from the bottom all right to make a
bezel we simply just gonna use the
revolve and this will be the curve and
we're gonna snapping into the zero as
our access and then we're gonna revolve
360 degree and then we look at the
center like that if this is going to be
your rendering you probably don't want
to do that is because this is look
really sharp for the rendering purpose I
will suggest you go it much lower and
something look like this and you want to
round it the ages
let's give it a small Filat 4.4
millimeter and you want to fit it here
and you also want to fit it there okay
and then let me do a comparison for you
we are going to use the same come in and
that's user revolve snapping into the
zero 360 degree and then we get that
there let's do a comparison by moving
this one to the side and we want to use
the render view for this as you can see
this one on the H it look much nicer
this one is really sharp so this one
will look much much better on the render
if you run the corner like that compare
this one this is for 3d printing and we
need to have enough room for chiller to
file the extra metal so since we are
planning to 3d printing this I'm going
to have this one stay like that
the next step is we need to decide it
where the the other the besetting is
going to be so I'm going to draw a
circle and roughly about this size I'm
gonna set it the stone it's about let's
go ahead to draw the circle first to
show where the stone is going to be
and then I won the stone is right on the
top I plan to have 1.3 mini metre stone
so we are going to use the offset come
in and we're gonna offset this curve
4.75 and we want to it hang both sides
so you get something like that you
should have a space in between here it's
about 1.5 and that will be for enough of
our 1.3 millimeters stone now bring in
the stone in the right size and we are
going to arrange the stone on it I'm
going to try with the array along the
curve and we are going to pick up this
object and we're gonna hit the base
curve let's try 36 and see how it goes
and he actually look pretty well I guess
right at the first time alright so now
we need to work on the prong I'm coming
over to the side view and I'm gonna draw
something somewhere right in the middle
something going like this and this will
be my curve gonna move this curve to
somewhere about here and we're simply
just going to pipe it let's pipe it with
the diameter 4.55 and see how you look
on it alright so it looks okay and let's
see if we can cover both of a stone
right there and then just cutting a
little bit about a stone alright it
looked nice to me and I'm going to
making a copy and make sure that you
want to equally place over there as well
in between the stone so once we have
this one we are going to we can simply
just using the polar array or you want
to array along the curve either one will
work I'm going to try array along the
curve and pick up the same base curve
using the same number over there and
click on this seaplane and name we will
get something like this make sure
everybody is nice and even it's not
sticking out to the line that we have
there alright so I'm going to giving a
little bit rimmed there because it's
really close to the stone so I'm going
to offset again for this curve that's
offset it for about pony full millimeter
and we're gonna offset this guy 4.4
millimeter and now we're gonna use those
two and make it into the solid by
extruded planar curve stray and I do
like to use both sides as well and
depends on how thick that you want it to
be on full of thickness now to make it a
little bit nicer we can giving a bevel a
bevel age so we want to use the command
it's called chamfer and I just wanted to
have the chamfer age is the same
distance we just set for point four
millimeters and we want to chamber this
one this one also the one on the bottom
they all point for meaning me so now you
look a little bit nicer now we can go
ahead to design whatever we like over
there by drawing the curve or depends on
how complicated you want it I simply
just want to do something like this I
want to draw a straight line and coming
to the top for whatever that it's going
to be and I'm gonna draw another
straight line coming over to here and
sometimes it will not be exactly on the
construction plane so we are going to
project to the sea plane and we want to
delete the input so now they are right
in the middle okay so that's work on the
top first I simply just gonna use the
piping come in and right here is about
this size on the top is a little bit
bigger and somewhere coming into this
area is a neck so it's gonna coming
something like this if this is too big
for you you can just
simply just scale it down and move it
like that this one as well I wanted this
one's about this why that why and go
somewhere in the middle
it's about thin air like this and we get
something like this to keeping the same
look but reduce your metal cost you
might want a 1d scale something like
that so it's not losing the look but it
giving a really good reducing on the
middle weight and we are going to use
the comments called polar ray we are
kind of snapping into the zero point in
number of item four eight 360 degree and
that's how we get this captain wheel and
all you need to do is to put the bell on
the top of it my new feature for the
membership option it's coming up really
soon I will talk about a lot of things
that is exclusive for member I hope you
will like it I will announce really soon
once its release thank you for watching
and I will see you next
[Music]